finally she starts telling me
she wants to let him know about us
okay and of course i fight that i says
no i mean he's not please you want to
get me killed i mean this is i know and
she laughs he would never do that he
loves you
anything i love he loves you know giving
me little hints that possibly
he knows
and i at that point i have no idea okay
and i still don't know the real exact
truth okay
so we
uh continue for a few more months few
more months now he sees me getting
erratic
i don't show up where i'm supposed to
show up because i think he's going to
kill me okay because now i started
seeing little things you know guys get
thrown out kicked out maybe cracked
around you know not major violence but
in the club the office
i may see one of the shylocks who's
hanging around
you know grabbing a guy by the throat
so i know it's not a nice nobody's
gotten killed yet though no one's gotten
shot or you haven't seen anything no
nothing like that yet but like i said i
have an uncle albert who's a dinosaur
with the uh colombo family he went back
all the way to junior persico's rise as
a matter of fact there's a scene in a
movie
well the godfather where
the guy's getting choked at the bar
junior persico was doing the choking
my uncle albert was in the crash car
outside
you know in real life
yeah yeah yeah so he was tight with
junior from way way back
uh
so
i knew it could i knew there was deaths
and
guys get killed you know brooklyn you
know especially back then you'd see a
body every couple of weeks somewhere you
know it wasn't odd and i didn't want to
be one of those bodies i started getting
paranoid so what year is this is this 80
already or 90. not quite 79. 79 pushing
80. okay about 18 months after we met so
you're 18 and a half 19 at this point
yes exactly and uh
so now
what happens is like i said he starts
seeing it so he starts saying things to
me little by little i don't like what's
what i see something wrong you got to
talk to me and i keep letting it go
letting it go
finally
uh
there's one specific instance where i
didn't show up and he was going to hit
somebody that night or they round up all
i had to do was drive him downtown
just drop me off
and i didn't show up
okay
and i found out later on
a friend bucky was killed that night
okay he was gonna have me drop him off
there and and if you if you follow the
mo as years go by
they give you little little bit little
tiny things to do
ultimately to bring you to a certain
level where you're asked to do more so
that little bit of a thing was his first
step
maybe he'd hear about it maybe he won't
very psychological and when you when you
bring your kid in okay and it's usually
an influential
male that you're you're you're following
that brings you in i got brought in by
an influential woman also
so like scarfa brought in leonetti and
leonetti was also young and
you know he was gradually getting him
through but scarfa was a
he was also a brutal guy but not 200
hits like
where scarpa stopped counting
he told me that he stopped counting 50.
then i heard later on you know higher
numbers uh then when i was away with him
and gas pipe
on mcc they were talking about numbers
between the two of them uh they said we
got over 200 between the two of us
that's where the 200k is this organizing
or is this a leading there's a big
difference to two right what do you mean
so so you you say you say no they're not
all authorized you're for yourself 25 as
you were involved in that's the number
that i read about you right yes what was
uh scarce number he
he was a shooter okay he never asked
anybody else to do the shooting unless
it was for a reason to make their bones
to get them
settled in and understand they're
capable
he never asked me to go anywhere alone
never asked me to do this never asked me
to even on a beatings well beatings a
lot of time it was greg junior would be
would be
he took that
as a badge of honor
that he didn't relegate it or say you
were gonna do it he says he'd get out of
the chair say let's go you know we go
them again this is later on which i'll
get to
so no but he was he was a shooter on the
scene uh i've heard about some hits that
aren't even
that public
you know that
you know
you can talk about it now everybody's
gone uh i wouldn't hate to cause trouble
for somebody that's why i say that even
though i made a deal with the government
i'm not looking to start trouble for
people uh it was never that way
but so anyway going back to this night
that was a pivotal night he knew
something was wrong with me
so she started telling me again
we're going to tell him we're going to
tell him and i made a comment back then
i said get me a bulletproof vest first
please because you can't tell him i mean
you know he's now with he's got to kill
him being sarcastic or seriously i was
half serious
you know i just
uh
so finally one day i get to the house
well what happens is
the supply company
has a big problem at the factory it
burns down
okay to this day i don't know if it was
done on purpose yeah you know in
hindsight probably probably a big
insurance check uh it's the mo nobody
really wants legitimate very common
strategies right right right
so
now i'm in no man's land
okay i i left college for this
the fire department test that i was very
high on i got a 99 underwritten and a 95
on the physical now 99 on the written i
should have got 100. it really it wasn't
a very difficult test i started saying
not it tried to trick me and you want to
know one of the questions was okay
you're walking past
a gas station you notice the pump is
leaking you a
stop and light up a cigarette
b
ignore it it's none of your business
c
call the fire department
d all the above obviously it's c so most
of the questions were like that and i
was laughing my way through it the
physical on the other hand guys were
throwing up at the end it was very
difficult so 95 i'm proud of
anyway i'm high on the list but what
happens is
that test
back in the day now this is back in
geez 81
80. i took the test in 80 probably 79
but as soon as i was 18 i took the test
and
it gets thrown out because
minorities had a problem with it and
women with the physical so a judge
in the federal courts takes two years to
rule on it
then he rules on it and sets another
test for two more years so four years is
going to go by before i could take the
test again
in that time she knows i'm in no man's
land she tells greg or asks him in front
of me we got to find something for larry
so i never forget the first thing out of
his mouth was
but we could get him in the numbers the
number business is the lowest form of
racket there is
nobody gets hurt there's no credit
uh
the biggest problem there is tax evasion
if you have a big number business okay
so i get in it with them
and they give me a few ideas of how to
build up numbers they give me a few
spots that are already working when i
say them it's greg and greg jr because
they're partners
i start
improvising on my own i start going to
and i'm already good with numbers i was
always good with numbers i go to the
local otbs i know there's all gamblers
in there i go to the bowling alleys
because they're all bowling for money
and i'm picking up numbers and they're
all giving them to me
now i start at the otbs
i start taking horse action otb is off
track betting i don't remember okay yeah
yeah it goes way back and it failed in
new york and i couldn't understand how
later on in life how you losing a
gambling proposition anyway so i started
not picking up horses so now i'm
bringing horses in i'm bringing
and i still don't have enough i get the
football tickets
okay the paul a cards again lowest form
of racket you could do but now i'm
making 500 800 a week back in
80. all cash yep
and i don't have to tell my parents i'm
not the manager anymore so i'm still
making a living and they're not asking
any questions you're living with your
parents i live in the basement apartment
got it yeah and
you know so now it is really nothing
looks out of ordinary other than
my first caddy when i pulled in the
first caddy i said no it comes with the
company you know and i've said along the
way
i said along the way and i don't mean it
in a bad way because i don't
consider myself a liar by no means i try
to be honest and ethical whatever the
word is
i got a lot of people that'll attest to
that
but certain situations you become a good
liar so if you like this sort of short
clip from an interview i did click over
here to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]